Airbnb is huge today.
On any given night you
could have as many as
2 million people staying in an
Airbnb all around the world.
You know, our mission is that everyone
can belong anywhere.
We're talking, you know,
300 million stays on any average year
and there's tyranny in numbers.
The vast majority of
Airbnb stays don't result
in a safety incident, but
sometimes things go wrong.
And for Airbnb, you know,
we're talking thousands
of safety incidents that occur every year
that the company has to
handle and has to respond to.
I'm talking situations like
kidnappings, hostage cases,
we're talking murder, we're talking rape,
we're talking, you know,
the worst violent crimes
that occur in our society
happen inside Airbnbs.
Airbnb never wants these kinds of cases
to end up in the headlines.
You know, that's really
bad for their brand,
their reputation, and their public image,
particularly because this is a business
that's based on strangers
trusting one another.
So when crimes like this occur,
that kind of threatens
their entire business model.
I'm Olivia Carville, I'm a reporter
on Bloomberg's Technology
team and I've been covering
online travel companies like
Airbnb for the last two years.
Airbnb is a startup that's
based in Silicon Valley
and like many of the
sharing economy startups
it managed to grow so big so fast
by essentially skirting regulations.
It was based on that premise
of move fast and break things
and it wanted to work against regulations
in order to grow as big as
possible and win the popular vote
because it became so popular so fast
that cities could no longer control it.
On a peak night this past
August, we had 1 million people
from around the world
coming from 180 countries
in a single night,
staying in an Airbnb home.
The vast majority of Airbnb
stays, we're talking, you know
2 million people staying in
an Airbnb on any given night,
don't result in a safety incident
but sometimes things go wrong.
And for the company, you know, it was,
dealing with these cases
was a really challenging,
difficult, complicated area.
You had hosts and guests and sometimes
they disagreed on what happened.
You had regulatory issues in
some of their biggest cities.
Then you also had, you know,
the growth of the platform
and the fact that if you're
going to try and prevent
some of these incidents,
it could cut into revenue
and cut into the number
of listings that you have.
So for Airbnb, it was
about trying to figure out
the best way to handle these
crises in a way that's going to
not only protect the individual in crisis,
but also protect the company's
public image, its brand,
its reputation, which is
essentially what its business
is based upon.
As Airbnb grew, like, way too big for them
to be able to take all these calls alone,
they developed a team of a
hundred highly specialized agents
that handle the worst of the worst cases.
Over the course of my reporting,
I've talked to almost 50
former employees at Airbnb
and you know, seven or eight
of those work directly on this elite unit.
These safety agents, many of them come
from military backgrounds
or trauma backgrounds.
They're trained to handle
traumatic situations
and to try and, you know, help
people who are going through
what, what may be, you know,
the worst day in their lives.
For these safety agents,
a lot of them understood
that they had a dual role.
First and foremost, they wanted to protect
the user in crisis but they also knew
they had a responsibility to protect
the company's brand and public image.
I mean, everything about
housing in New York
is a total mess and it's always chaotic.
It's not too surprising
that Airbnb's biggest battle
has broken out here.
2015 was a really
challenging year for Airbnb.
Airbnb's listings between 2010 and 2014
were essentially illegal hotels.
You know, the company was seven years old now,
it had grown huge, it
was now a household name.
But by growing that big that
fast they also came up against,
you know, a pushback in regulations.
Now, Airbnb's under attack
in a lot of major cities.
Yeah, so what are they saying about this?
I mean -
They are, well, they can't
give up on New York, 'cause
New York's too important
for every kind of reason.
They knew that they couldn't
lose the battle in New York
because it was one of
their biggest markets
and also it could result
in a domino effect.
If other cities around
America saw New York City
either backing down on regulations
or enforcing stricter
regulations that could in turn
be rolled out right across the country.
I think it's gonna be awkward
when they have to, you know
putting their prospectus,
their risk factors
when they have to say,
well, you know, one risk
is that the whole thing
might be somewhat illegal
in our biggest market.
And in December of that year,
a young woman from Australia
flew into New York and stayed at an Airbnb
with a group of her friends.
They picked up a key from
the local corner bodega
without even needing identification.
The police report said
this 29 year old woman
left her friends at a Midtown bar
and returned to the Airbnb on her own.
She thought that she was
alone, but she wasn't.
There was a man inside the apartment
hiding in the shadows
with a kitchen knife.
He grabbed her, dragged her
into a room and raped her.
He later fled.
About an hour after
this attack he came back
and police were in the
apartment at the time.
They opened his backpack and
found three items of interest,
the kitchen knife, one
of the woman's earrings,
and a set of keys to the Airbnb.
This case was a really
complicated one for Airbnb,
partly because it
occurred in New York City
where they were fighting
this really tough battle
with city officials over regulations.
And partly because the
alleged rapist had the keys
and he was inside the apartment.
That meant that Airbnb
needed to do what it could
to protect itself.
They wanted to find out, you
know, how did he get the keys?
That was a really big question for them.
They launched an investigation
to find that out,
but before they did anything like that,
before they thought to kind of protect
their own reputation
here they really focused
on doing what they could
to help this young woman.
They paid for her to move to a hotel.
They paid for her mother
to fly in from Australia.
They paid for both of them to fly home.
They offered to cover any
health or counselling costs
that she might need later.
But inside the company internally,
they also launched an investigation.
They wanted to know how did the
alleged rapist get the keys?
How did he get inside that Airbnb?
And when they found out
that the keys had been left
at the corner bodega, that
then created, you know,
a problem of liability for Airbnb.
They didn't have a policy
around key exchange.
They didn't tell their hosts how they did
or didn't have to hand keys over to guests
as they were arriving.
So for Airbnb, they also, you know,
they wanted to know what was
going to be said in court.
They wanted to know if any
media were going to pick up
on the story and they wanted to know
what their legal liability
potentially could be.
A week later, the alleged
rapist was indicted
in the Supreme Court in New York
and Airbnb sent a staff member to find out
if the company was going to be mentioned
in any of the court records.
And it wasn't, it wasn't
mentioned in the police report.
It wasn't mentioned by prosecutors.
There's no mention of Airbnb
really in any public record.
This case has never
been reported until now.
And you know, for Airbnb,
that was kind of lucky,
this case never landed in the media.
And you know, 18 months later
when this woman's lawyer
reached out to the company,
they signed a settlement for $7 million
and part of that settlement,
there's a clause that says
she cannot assert or imply responsibility
on the part of the company.
We've spoken to legal experts who indicate
that what this really did
is gag the woman from saying
"I blame Airbnb".
Airbnb is one of the few
companies in the world
that has this like online-offline
kind of hybrid situation
where you have users who meet online
and then actually meet
in the offline world
and stay under the same roof.
And that means that the
company at the end of the day
really has to take more responsibility
than other social media
platforms might do.
With Airbnb's terms of service,
that really means that
whenever there's a dispute
between hosts and guests and the company,
this is all handled behind
closed doors and arbitration.
Most of these cases don't
even make it to the courtroom
and when they do the
company will settle them
so it doesn't go on through the courts.
And what that means is that
there hasn't really been
a legal precedent that's set
to determine what Airbnb's
liability is here.
You know, is it really responsible
for when things go wrong
inside its listings?
What I learned over the
course of my reporting
is that this is anything but simple.
This is a complicated, nuanced area.
There are difficult trade-offs here.
The company also has
to have hard, you know,
tough conversations about policy.
Airbnb's business model
is based on strangers
trusting one another.
We often hear from the founders
and the chief executive
himself saying trust is
their number one priority.
I've actually heard Brian
Chesky, the chief executive
of Airbnb talking about how
he didn't build a website
or a platform that allows people to stay
in each other's homes,
what he built was a community
that trusts one another.
And when that premise
has undercut Airbnb's
entire business model is under threat.